I want to turn it to Terry for a moment
because he's growing up in Little Rock
and in 1957 your age 15 and you'd make a
very courageous decision and joined this
group of nine students who attempt to
integrate the high school fear was my
constant companion not just at Central
High School in 57 but even prior to that
just based on being a black kid in this
country and and I'd like to say in this
country rather than the south because
too often people have a misconception
about the South anything south of Canada
is a south so you you have to understand
- growing up as a black kid we did not
have the luxury of being safe as you
were there was no such thing we had to
know how to survive and you can't
survive unless you know the truth of
your surrounding you have to understand
who people are and what their attitudes
might be you know and also Little Rock
was not an isolated incident that just
happened in time and space it was
predictable
based on who we had been up until that
point we the people you see in 1954 when
the Supreme Court ruled in the brown
case that it was no longer
constitutional to discriminate that was
in isolation because nothing else
changed the social the cultural
ideological the sociological the
emotional the visceral all remained
quite the same that's why Little Rock
erupted as it did in 1957 this was
something that was unimaginable to the
minds of those of us who wanted to
maintain the status quo after a year of
that experience you ended up having your
family all moved here to Los Angeles
because a school right the governor
closed the schools which was a favorite
ploy during that time to close schools
in Little Rock was certainly not the
most egregious example of that kind of
thing and Prince Edward County Virginia
schools were closed for four consecutive
years not just high schools but
elementary and middle schools as well
now do you remember when the book was
published in 1960 or when the film came
out did that make an impact in your life
you were still oh yeah I mean you know
young man at the time the mockingbird
and it still remains quite a classic
film for a number of reasons not the
least of which is that it is
contemporary it was as if it were made
yesterday because the themes are so
current absolutely the film is so
resonant Menai I was just I was just so
struck by how resonant it is and yet how
far we've come
it's both it's it's still resonant the
themes are still there the the very
carefully protected and crafted
alternate reality is still here we have
a different alternate reality here in
Los Angeles because the surf class is
more complicated it's now immigrants
poor immigrants poor african-americans
there is still slavery it's in 21st
century we have it here in the backyard
of LA we have slavery and yet and still
look at look at the conflicts that were
going through now with the same themes
but there's a difference the difference
in for example the the Martin Trayvon
Martin killing you see a multiracial
outrage it's not just african-americans
and in the Tulsa shootings the Tulsa
shootings Tulsa was the most terrifying
place I've ever been
it was scared me and I was there two
years ago that's almost like a time warp
when I go to Tulsa but a huge difference
in wouldn't sound like very much to us
perhaps you're sitting in LA the
relative tolerance of LA and our melting
pot of LA well it's actually more like a
salad bowl but in Tulsa the tips that
caught the two shooters came in from
white residents of Tulsa I see the
dynamics changing but I've lived all
over the world I lived the opposite
experience that you didn't either does
touken I did not live in sick okay I
didn't live in Jim Crow I have lived all
around the world in the Air Force the
Air Force was not integrated we were
often the only African American family
so I had the inverse experience of the
two of you but we are still not
integrated and when Martin Luther King
said you cannot achieve multiracial
democracy with Universal opportunity by
class by race by all of the fault lines
we have a million human fault lines and
you can't create that Society of
universal opportunity and fairness a
multiracial pluralistic society without
full integration and we're still not and
we ended desegregation we ended the
brutality for the most part but instead
we stopped and we need to pick that
baton up and run like the wind because
we still have time but I think of
Atticus Finch the sort of best in all of
us who can stand against their tribe
that's the hardest thing to do is to
stand against the fears of your own
tribe I've probably had to stand against
my tribe more as african-americans get
used to Latinos being the emergency
which the emerging majority as I said as
I said to Pat Morris before she left I
said you know listening to Americans
talk about race is a little like
listening to nuns talk about sex it's
always very interesting and a little
two-dimensional